Neal
welcome to the GSB thank you for having
me here really excited to have you here
today
SSS guess we'll go speaker series so as
Mario mentioned in the introduction you
have had an incredible career
internationally and over the next 40
minutes we'll love to talk about your
personal journey both as entrepreneur as
well as an investor and will love to
hear your thoughts on the huge and
exciting market in China today we also
open up the last 20 minutes for
questions from the audience so to get us
started so know you grew up in China and
in 1989 you came to the US initially for
a ph.d program in math and you made the
decision to do an MBA a year after that
very validating for the MBA is here to
here at that time we caught an EMPI p.m.
I was telling people that this is like
MBA and oftentime need a lot
explanations and huge fills to go into
banking straight after your MBA so I'm
going to take us to the year 1999 at
this point you've been banking for eight
years you're running China capital
markets with Deutsche Bank and you're
doing really well in your career but at
this point you choose to make two pretty
big decisions one you leave banking to
start your own business until you
decided to move back to China tell us
more about your thoughts behind that
decision I think I can talk a little bit
sort of the thoughts are proud to my
decision to go back to China Stassi
chirp I think you know as someone who
are left China after four years of
college we always want to do something
for China or around China obviously you
know upon graduation from child home
probably the best choice for me at a
time is you know go to us and study but
while I was in New York I always
thinking can I do something you know can
i leverage my China experience or
background so
you know 1992-1994 there is a
opportunity that you can go back to
China and be part of the so-called
capital markets efforts right you know
many you know students who study in the
US or work in the US before end up join
those you know Asian branch of you know
a big investment bank and I'm part of
them and you get it very sadly because
when you go back you see how much China
has been changed from the 1980s you know
you know against the time when I left
China so you really feel like you know a
lot of things you can do but back in you
know 1994-95 most of the so-called
economic reform around big enterprises
especially SOS what really actually have
changed is toward the end of 1990 you
know you know the 1990s when private
enterprises come to become one of the
major force in the whole economic
development and so people like myself
when I first working in you know in the
events in banking world in China my
major customers are you know the Chinese
corporates I'm the first one knock at
door at this you know c-note at the Bank
of China and then you're starting to
find that their opportunity to do
financings for private companies and
because of that you're thinking about
whether you can be part of them at that
time you know entrepreneurship was not a
popular war and people like myself was
saying probably I don't I know I don't
have much opportunity you know to do
that because you need a lot you know you
know very large amount of capital I mean
the first batch of Chinese and you know
our private enterprises typically are in
the area like you know Manufacturing's
transfer from the shunran's year the so
called you know the you know those are
county enterprises before all the real
estate developers and who made the first
sort of you know there are gold and then
you know venture into our other areas
but
or people like myself who has now you
know do not have a lot of capital
they're not mature you know I'm really I
can do until internet time to play and I
have to say you know us forgive me the
inspiration I came to a Silicon Valley
very oftenly
because I have a lot of classmates while
working in different tech firms here
from 1998 all the way to 2000 each time
when I came I noticed a big changes
because many of those who work at Oracle
s AP I've been you know before has
switched to internet jobs and when I
walking through you know the you know
all those you know on drive through you
know a 101 you see the big billboard
change from advertisement from big
companies to Internet companies so you
see the internet is really changing how
people live and work here in US and
naturally you will think well if this is
gonna be the case in u.s. it should
happen in China so I have to say the
first batch of you know internet
entrepreneur in China whether it's by
due or tension or sea trip or getting
spouts because these successful models
in the US and we know we can do
similarly like our US counterparts
basically you know not a lot of care to
yourself but you can use venture capital
to help you you know to grow your
business so you know my first venture RC
trip you know it's exactly follow that
you know a route you know Expedia was
doing very good and we think well if
expedient could be could change the
travel industry so much in us why not in
China so that's how I started you know
see chip in um in 1999
frankly it's a very difficult decision
if I'm a you know software you know
engineer it's probably a natural
extension of my previous professions but
I would a banker right banker provides
advice to the corporates and ah
you know merge acquisitions deafening
sings IPOs and unchanged by road
completely to something very very new to
me right and it was a very very big
venture for me and the only thing I'm
comfortable is that I know if I'm not
successful I can always go back because
if Dortmund do not hire me there's
someone else gonna hire me look back is
actually not very good you know
mentality because when you do
entrepreneurship but you better be so
determined that you will make it
successful not just to hope in that one
day you're gonna go back you should not
leave yourself any other possibilities
but that's how I you know started I do
know I have possibilities if I can't be
successful and I clear I understand
there there's a good chance that I you
know I might not I can go back and maybe
another bank and Jaime um but you know
when I really get involved with a
start-up you don't have time to think
about anything because you won't survive
and you want to do well everyday you are
just so heavily engaged with your you
know surviving you know arm efforts
indeed I would say in the in the first
two years you try to find your penis
model and you know you work day and
night you don't have time even to think
about with my you know other
alternatives you don't yeah I actually
just tell you guys you know you know I a
little story when I had resigned from
Deutsche Bank my boss the head of Asia
capital markets say Neil you should stay
four more months
I should wear four more months because
euro is just created you know you know
around the time and the euro was
introduced as a major currency I was a
fixed income banker and I have been
covered Minister of Finance of China for
you know many years and major finance is
has a plan to go to Europe you know
Europe to actually our launch its first
euro bond so my part to me look you know
you have been
the cons for so many years it's your
pride to actually launch a Euro bound
for Minister of Finance
and this is your country you'll be so
proud of you know you know doing that
just wait for four months and I checked
with my partners and I said Neil you
can't wait for four months and your
fellowship is about speed another four
months you don't know what can happen so
I just had to quit in November December
instead of wait until that you know that
you know spring in 2000 interestingly I
was I never regret that decision because
that Europe and was not launched until
year 2003 euro was not doing well as you
guys all know right hey and the Europe
coming down and the Ministry of Finance
said no no no I don't do it so they wait
until 2000 or - 2003 to actually hit
launch the euro bond so I go back to
tell my boss later become an independent
threat of sea trip I said look if I wait
for four years four months I can wait
for another ten months and well maybe
two years and they'll never be a sea
trip so if you like to do something if
you really feel like you know there's
something calling you inside you better
do it right away and that's about all
about intrapreneurship so I you said you
know you could always go back to banking
if you weren't doing well well you were
doing very well with the trip you
started in 1999 in just four years you
know before the Euro bomb was launched
you brought it public listen on NASDAQ
and what's amazing it's just not even
the only company you found a successful
in that period in 2002 you found that
Homans now one of the largest hotel
chains in China here in more than 300
cities close to 3,000 hotel chains and
they also for years listed on NASDAQ how
do you do it you know what do you think
is contributed to your success as
entrepreneur I think it's um you know
very importantly that once you get into
the business um you are able to really
understand the sector very well instead
of just looking at your own business and
say you know I'm doing my daily
execution so at a sea trip it's really a
very I open opportunity for me for the
whole Hospital
industry you realize all the Chinese
travel you see our soul back or in terms
of the IT systems and there's so much
middleman involved in bringing a
customer whether it's business or
leisure to the ultimate destinations
there's so much you can do obviously as
a company you can't just want just one
issue but you do you know get to know a
lot about a whole you know um industry
one thing we which which we notice well
I you know I work in LSE chip is our
upstream so-called you know the hotel
industry itself is again is very very
underdeveloped
for example there's many so-called you
know on business hotel or economy hotel
chains in the US but in China back in
2002 and 2003 there's almost none in the
and and it actually shocks me that
there's no such hotel which catering to
a specific needs and when we launch home
inside initially I was a little bit
concerned
how big a company could be because you
know each hotels is small hundred room
150 rooms and how big a company does
cook you know become or whether China's
ready but again I got inspiration from
you know us I remember I was in you know
Dallas visiting a few travel service
company because that was the hub of many
US you know travel you know service
companies and I arrived at the airport I
rent a car try from the airport all the
way to downtown it was like night time
around 9:00 p.m. whatever
and during that 20 to 30 minutes drive I
observed there's about 15 names you know
different names of budget hotels or
iconic or touching from real oof all the
way to motel 6 whatever and the total
number of hotels are counted around 25
so from Dallas from suburban airport to
the city you can have 25 hotels so I say
well Marcus says not a problem for China
then indeed I never imagined we can have
3,000 hotels in China you know by all
means and there's all created by you
know our efforts and as well as
obviously many of our competitors and
the market is definitely there because
the demand is so big and we just need to
creating good product to catering to the
users to me quite a few transitions
going from a PhD to MBA and then banking
to entrepreneurship in 2005 you make yet
another big decision going from being an
entrepreneur to becoming the
entrepreneur behind entrepreneurs and
what's really interesting is you could
have chosen to start your own fund which
I'm sure you have plenty of resources to
do but instead you decided to be a
franchise firm with Sequoia Capital this
really was established American brand
what was some of these considerations
behind breena's global brand to China
well I think you know first of all you
know if you look at it in my career from
yeah from PhD program I'll never get a
PhD so MBAs or and not not MVM PPM's
into banking etc I don't see we have
many choice back then and this is
something which you guys you know you
know you know compare with us you guys
are so lucky I'm talking about you know
you know especially those public student
from China because you know when I you
know arrived in New York I don't think I
can get into business school right away
and again after business school you know
you don't have many choices either and
oftentimes you're never going through
internship or prior working experience
so can tell you what's your best fit for
you but what actually drives me to make
those choices is that you see the great
opportunity and also you go with the
whole trend and the last 23 years
the big trend is that you think the
China is going to become you know a a
global economy a Paul house and if you
believe in that
and you know in the a you know a poker
term you call it if you're only in China
you were largely doing well and I guess
that's probably gonna be the case for
the next 10 20 years
if you you know so called a candle of
you be long China or even more so yeah
you know you know Oh in China you're
likely to do well and coming back to
doing you know venture capital I always
think that probably the best fit for me
after spending seven years at the banker
and then another six years as an
entrepreneur is getting to an investment
field because you can leverage your
experience both as a financier as well
as as a entrepreneur so that's something
which I think to probably fit me very
well clearly I never planned that I
never get in the bank and say hey one
day I do sign to preneur ship and then
how can best fit myself for as a venture
capitalist you know I never do that
saying when I see trip I always want to
survive and and it makes each of a great
company never seeing that okay this
experience can position myself be a good
entry you know be a good venture cabinet
you know sometime down row now I I can
do a for myself indeed I made some
personal investment while at you know
sea trip and some of those are very
successful like folks media ye house but
I was thinking how I can sort of best
leverage my experience at the same time
can really make an investment and had a
big impact on the whole you know
so-called new economy you can you can
set up you know a if I myself but I
think it's gonna be grow a or public not
as fast compared with you know setting
on something with Sequoia and also I
feel like I really want to learn from
what a firm like Sequoia has been you
know you know accumulated in the last 40
years you know in Silicon Valley that
many firms has been active in
you know the investment space but
Sequoia has been obviously did you know
there in the longest and still probably
the best or if not you know oh I would
say at least one of the best so I was
very intrigued how they can do that one
generation after another so we are to
raise money to make investment is
probably not the most difficult thing
but the most important you're saying is
how to make a sustainable business to me
I think you know Sequoia China is just a
you know another venture if you want to
make one or two you know good investment
that's a easy job but how you can build
a team and how to make it's a simple
business just like what I did at C chip
I think that's a very very different
thing and and you know today look back
after ten years I'm very happy you know
the choice I made because you know at
our ten-year anniversary we have a long
list or entrepreneur which becomes
Sequoia portfolio our CEOs but more
important from ten years ago a
three-person four-person team today we
have tall partners and we have covered
some of the most important sectors in
China and become invested in many of the
leading companies and that's something
which probably difficult to achieve just
with one man's efforts always Neosho
brands so on that topic
you know Sequoia Capital in China for
the last years has a phenomenal track
record if pretty much put money in all
of China's biggest unicorns Alibaba and
JT comm VIP shop you know people call
you China's Midas you turn stone into
gold what do you think makes you so
successful investor especially in China
what's your secret sauce well I think
you know this um venture capital
investment is a is a you know is a is a
professional over has a regret
clearly we have a lot of very successful
you know companies but obviously we also
have a lot of regrets and and frankly
you know mistakes and the good thing is
you learn from your mistakes and then
you try to improve every year the others
seem very very important is we
look at the sequoia us they have fully
history they have a long list of success
Oracle you know Cisco Apple and then
Google and you know cetera et cetera and
what a reason behind that is they able
to capture all the major trend and they
are able to say no to some trend which
turn out to be is are just pure um
illusions and that's I think it's the
probably most important factors behind
you know the success of firms like
Sequoia it seemed for us um in China if
there's any so-called success for us
then that's you know I think we have
been really taking you know you know the
major a trend right I remember back
seven years ago we have decided that we
should spend enough time and put enough
of investment into e-commerce area we do
have a view that ecommerce peak or
becomes very very important in China
probably even more important compared
with you know in you know the retail
space in the US so we invest probably
around 15 ecomes company in China some
of those are not successful but we did
capture the top five to six in a very
successful year
it comes in China same for o twelve
offline to online is not a big space in
the US but it was a big stage and it
continued to be a very important space
for China we think this is a you know
you know um you know I am a very
important area for us and we did a lot
of research back four or five years ago
we invest probably around again twelve
to fifteen company and we happen to
capture the very top four companies you
know from mid want to dampen to a llama
to data and that's the way I think you
know I think public you know good firms
should make investment
you actually have a view on the market
and hopefully a little bit earlier than
you know most other people and you put
big emphasize on the sectors and making
multiple investment index you know arm
in in that sectors and this is same for
you you know on us if you look at
Sequoia back in forty years ago they pay
big attention to you know semiconductors
and then summer conductor you know leads
to personal computer and they again
invest multiple company in personal
computer and then to put and and and
then to software companies and then when
internet you know comes become you know
the major scene they invest multiple
internet companies and then go into you
know mobile internet that is the way I
think you know uh you know a good
investor should follow the investing you
know I'm you know match about it
there's always something which you were
missed you know picked up because of
judgment on person you know all judgment
on particular business model but that's
okay
you always will make mistakes but you as
long as you capture all the major trends
you'll be doing very refined and
sometimes it were including to say no to
some sectors I remember seven eight
years ago clean tech is a buzzwords both
here in the US as well in China and
luckily our us partners as well as our
China promise decided there's not a big
area
you know fundamentally it's not easy to
creating large market caps by investing
in a venture capital or even private
equities into that sectors indeed after
ten years anyone can remember like what
are the top you know multi-billion
dollar company all the space nothing
right and avoid those saw pitfalls is
again very very important because there
are certain firms spend one-third of the
time and money into the space and they
end up finding this is actually not much
there and this is a you know and and you
know and and I think this is probably
the most important
you know efforts and and you know I'm
judgmental cause coming on to on
companies you always warm it mistake I
remember when we look at you know from
the video space back to knowing you know
I'm nine years ago will actually light
the space and we actually put a lot of
efforts on it and us secure has invested
in you in YouTube very successful we
picked the number three a player in that
space and end up it's just a small game
for us and these things will happen all
the time because you know you may not be
you know - all right for judging a
particular entrepreneur in that
particular case the companies found
there was not very good at the marketing
and happened to be that the marketing is
the key efforts for a video sharing
companies and and sometimes you get
lucky like you know in our case VIP shop
or JD or you know recent case like a
mate one damping but the big trend is
lot more important to Colin right on one
particular companies the auditing as
some of this major trends going forward
what excites you about China today I
think you know our every couple year
there's always some technology
breakthroughs and the last five years in
the US the big theme is big data sauce
enterprises and it's not a big thing in
China yet but I think it's becoming
increasing importance in fact I would
think you know the returnees from this
part of the world especially from
Silicon Valley might have a better role
to play in China if you talk about Big
Data in salsa
and in devices China in you know in this
time is like us five six years ago when
it come down to enterprises software's
sauce enterprises a sauce and in big
data's so I think this is actually a
great opportunity and just like we 1999
there's many big internet company us
being founded
channel you know there's very few area
has been covered and this is a very much
comparable and when you come down to the
for the return is to go back to a
founding company I think this is
actually a very good area because if you
talk about consumer internet you may not
able to compete successfully against
so-called you know the local guide
because in the consumer internet space
the cultural factor is so heavy you have
to understand your user very well if you
work in the US for too long you may not
have to do that if you look at that you
know like Charles tongue and if you like
a robbing Lee when they go back to China
they don't really have a very long
working experience here in the US still
not like you know early employer Yahoo
or you know early employee of Google to
go back to founding Chinese companies
but in the enterprises area the
technology component is more important
so people who work here for many years
in their space could actually play a
very important role in shaping up the
space in China so I think this is
definitely you know a very important
area the other important area is
so-called in robotics or artificial a
and AI in areas again in that area the
mini US company ahead of you you know on
China but China started to see some
local born companies which had
developing its own technology complex
DJI right you know it definitely the
number one player in the drone space and
so I think we will probably see some you
know interesting dynamics even the you
know channel Chinese company will you
know doing better than some of us you
know I'm us company addressing those you
know major trends but you know just like
what do we seeing before every couple
years this new technology breakthrough
and bringing you you know um
commercial opportunity but relative
speaking I think China's opportunity
might be bigger compared with you
because because the you know the
so-called the efficiency in the
traditional industry is the world behind
compared with us
that's why ecommerce could do so well in
you know a China compared with the US
and same for all twas so what we're on
the topic of you know American companies
in China China's a huge market growing
second largest economy in the world and
Sequoia China has actually also been
working with a lot of these American
companies you've invested LinkedIn
you're a strategic partner with Airbnb
so for you what did he have some of this
biggest opportunities and especially
challenges who American companies enter
in China and what Sequoia is role in
helping them navigate this if you're
looking at global companies especially
US companies coming to China I see in
the first thirty years forty years when
China opened or many US company has been
very successful because the technology
is so advanced that they when you come
to China there's no competition like
when GM come to China people love it
even though she may not be the best it's
a mobile auto mobile company in the
world right and there's a lot of joint
venture get set up so at that time you
know the key word in the joint venture
is use technology to gain market share
right you young chui's who wants to talk
so whether it's European players or
American compare often time set up their
own subsidiaries or set up a joint
venture in China and they could do very
well against the competition either
against the private company all against
the steel enterprises but things has
been really changed many sectors today
the private companies in China and still
enterprises in China are very
competitive they've learned they have
developed in their own Rd and they can
really compete very effectively with you
right
when P&G goes to China when Jim go to
China back three years ago
the dominant southern space today they
had to compete faithfully with many
local players so what our idea here is
that if the China s company come to
China just copy what they have been done
in US it may not be that effective
anymore so you have to have to change
your model and your you know your
product to cater to China small you know
um very unique you know on business
environment especially in the internet
space because internet for internet
China and us start around the same time
for some business model China even
advanced compared with us for example
Tencent you know today clearly much
better than you know some of those
social network companies in China you
can't say tensing is learn from you know
Facebook or copycat Facebook in fact if
you like your Facebook and you know many
others some of those features I learned
from Chinese companies so if a internet
company in us want to go to China they
have to think about whether they have
etched there or not
secondly they're gonna have to face the
competition from local companies many
driven by very very strong entrepreneurs
so how are going to be successful once
in which we suggest is to having a very
unique shareholding structures you
should introduce someone as entrepreneur
as in your home country someone not
listen to the head office but someone
able to based his product and service
around Chinese unique businesses you
know environment and leverage the edge
from head office that's how we did it on
you know the linking joint ventures and
that's what a why you know our try where
you are try very hard for mbmb the
product of linking and mbmb are
wonderful there's no question about it
but there are some local competitors
there CEOs and their founders are very
strong and you need to have a structure
where the guy who run Lincoln China has
a direct interest in running their
business so the management team need to
be compensated properly and not just
compensated at a head office and I think
that you know that's probably the best
way for a you know US company to you
know to compete and do well in China in
fact if a Chinese company come to
Silicon Valley they should do the same
thing right if they've send something
from you know someone from head office
and try to try to compete with local
company here in the US I don't think
they have a chance but they had too high
the best talent in Silicon Valley and
give them the enough economic interest
let them run the show and then leverage
the backend from China and then you
might have a chance to competing locally
that's I think it is the model moving
forward apropos for both US company as
well for Chinese companies so that's how
we actually bring link into China and
that's how we bring mbmb China and I
think this is probably a model that will
you know see if that's fit for many
other US companies even though they are
already very very successful here in the
US and as the business partner what do
we bring to the table is that we're
helping to get the best team and and
also to put all resources behind it and
to make sure that you have the right
partners are for your efforts and
actually it's very is it's not easy to
find such so-called local CEOs because
he needs to be very entrepreneur as I
mentioned at the same time he had to
understand how to working with a large
organizations because you do want to
leverage your head office some of you
know some of the existing technology arm
infrastructures and someone who know how
to make sure you know the rest the
respective department within your head
office can work with you very closely so
it's difficult to find the stuff talent
but you know and and and a it's it's um
it's a tough job and we have been try
very hard and so far that
have been quite successful with linking
and hopefully we can extend it to two
other US companies definitely want to
stay Airbnb in China so now have two
questions from the audience we have
Maria and Eve on either side please
raise your hand high if you're
interesting asking the questions so they
can spot you you can also tweet to our
hashtag stand for GSS even have a
question and I think we'll start with a
question from Twitter
right so thank you both for such an
inspirational discussion now the first
question from Twitter many of us here
aspire to be entrepreneurs and see
China's a great market opportunity but
what are some of the unique challenges
that entrepreneurs face in China and how
do you recommend we overcome them I
think one of the most frequently sort of
encountered challenge is a competition
it's it's actually interesting
I always very puzzled and I still do not
have the perfect answer here in the u.s.
in Silicon Valley have one penis model
typically no one either care to cut you
know to you know copy or no one really
you know uh you know you know I need to
copy if you you know you have over you
have mbmb you have linking there's very
few copycats in China as long as your
penis is doing well you will definitely
have copycats ah it's a matter of how to
compete more successfully and and and
that actually going to putting pressure
on the leaders to innovate all the time
right I remember when I was running
teacher one of the my looting job is
come to Monday meeting and discuss how
our competitor was doing especially
alone right so one of the one uh one on
Monday discussion item is you know
spending thirty minutes and discuss
what's Elam has been launched in the
last one week and indeed I have to say
you know many of those are copied what
teacher been doing on someone's very
detailed like you know marketing plans
like sending cards at the airport when
we do that they do that so what okay
so you just have to innovate all the
time just to make sure you stay ahead of
the game and it's a rarity and people
have to face many business models
you cannot IP it and and you just have
to you know raise more money you just
have to you know innovate all the time
age and you just have to differentiate
yourself well enough and that
differentiation sometimes coming down to
very details when we look at c3 vs.
alone at a time we are around two times
bigger than alone and what differentiate
we have is through Co center with
providing better services that's I
should become a big edge and if you
coming down to merchants relationship
when we establish the student
relationship with you know a hotel group
they follow you know that relationship
you know it's difficult to do it you
know exclusive deals but only is in
which we have been done well and
differential self is a better customer
services and and so in and you can call
that actually a small details but that's
more detail really bring in a very big
change you know are being very big lack
of force each against Iran and so for
China if you want to get into those
competitive space you have to be
prepared and to innovate all the times
and and the other thing I want to paly
part out is that it's difficult to
retain talent in Silicon Valley because
people gonna strike out on his own it's
even more difficult to do so in China if
you're looking at a turnover rate at a
major Internet companies in China it's
actually higher a lot high compared with
US companies many company feel like you
know sorry many seniors that you feel
like asked you know to do startup today
you know the environments so good
there's so many people you know you know
so much money you know I chase after
them and they owe and and especially in
the mobile internet space
the entry barrier to start up something
Israel you know is retro uh so we do see
people willing to consider do something
on his own instead of staying with a
large company and so I think that's a
challenge that how to retain people and
obviously you know compensation is one
way yo up on etc but also to build a
very strong culture to make sure that
you know your top people could stay well
thank you for sharing with us I'm
topping MBA one so I'm really curious to
see how you can evaluate a company with
a trend that is it's kind of uncertain
so earlier you mentioned that big data
is one of the trends and with in big
data there's gonna be a lot of different
sectors medicine education you name it
can you maybe walk through us here are
some insights on how you would actually
have a quantifiable metrics within those
big data sectors to determine which one
would be potentially successful I think
there's a few common a sort of checking
point we will you know look at when
we're looking at any of you know stand
up this is same whether it's consumer
internet or with the SAS Enterprise one
is obviously the you know the background
of the team whether actually fit for
that type of you know entrepreneurship
for example if it's ecommerce I would be
very you know II got to know whether he
has our consumer experience whether he
has supplied experience but for SAS
enterprises I would look to see if he
has you know the relevant software
experience or enterprise's experience
you know arm before secondly I will also
look at the market size that's actually
very very important if you look at
ecommerce area you know the reason why
JD become you know one of the top
Internet companies in China because they
just you know the most important area
you know at the very beginning the three
see the consumer you know arm the
consumer electronics if you stop some
from something else for example you
focus on books they want they you may
not get as a pick as you grow
so the you know total or just amok is
always something you know very important
especially in the first one to two years
you can always expand from your core
areas after you become successful so in
the southern parts the area you have to
start from some verticals and the
question here is whether that vertical
is big enough for you to become a very
substantial leader and you can expand
from that reality is to point the other
very important I think area to look
after is whether the time is right
because enterprises demand in China is
clearly there but people have priorities
for particular corporates they look at
it how much you know money on spend on
and on indepence oft where and what are
the key you know sort of area I won't
put money this year against a year later
or two year later
so for enterprises software you should
look at those area which corporate are
having the most pain in increasing
efficiency we look at our securities we
look at storage we look at performance
areas we look at hrs some of the areas
which clearly with the writing labour
cost you have to dress in those issues
and I think that's probably a important
point for venture capitalists as a word
for inter you know for a entrepreneur
want to start business in the sector
thank you mr. Shane for your species is
very inspiring so my passionate about
people when you was a part of starship
how did you find your partners
because without partners it's impossible
for startups are successful and the same
as here like them now if we want to
build up us startup in China how what's
the most effective way to find the
perfect punters thank you it's difficult
to find profit partners but as long as
you find good partners that's okay ah
when I look at in many startups when
they walked into our conference you know
conference room to present you know to
be honest
also the team at the so-called NGO stage
or seriously staged to not have a
complete team but you need to have some
core team member and addressing the
major or needs you know in in the siege
of days we have myself and James and
chichi frankly it's a little bit crowded
teeth but we got three guy I already
have lot experience in different
business segments but even with the
three people we decide to find famine
will who has worked at the Chow industry
for many years because we do realize
online travel is about internet but at
the same time it's about travel so we
want someone who understand the travel
industry a lot about you know how to
build a relationship with hotels how to
you know position ourselves against you
know all the other traditional travel
agencies so these are very interesting
questions you have to address and you
find someone who can complement your
skill set and to addressing those issues
and if you're gonna have a so-called
core team at the first not a complete
team then try to find what are the most
critical component of your startup like
e-commerce then you have to better have
someone who understand supply chain if
you know if you do not have someone
experienced in that secondment you don't
even have the business taking off but
maybe someone who you know do a better
job to you know doing online marketing
comes second it's still very important
but it's not the most critical and the
day one so I think you know you just
have to go along with your you know your
your your business or you know our
ramped up to find that you can gradually
they want to find a complete team is
always challenged I think we have time
for one last question from the audience
oh I know thanks for your time my
question is which is a bigger bubble of
China or southern Valley I want to be
more I actually want to be more specific
so here's a thought experiment if uber
erases another round right now and if
the last latest round investors are
guaranteed a three times return would
you be an investor thanks I don't want
to comment specifically on
the hooper case but I don't see a
so-called a big bubble there because I
don't day you ask yourself are those
startups really creating values if they
do creating values are all almost of the
startup companies are creating values
I'm not particularly worried valuation
there's always up and down if you look
at a public market they're always up and
down anyway and so I would not
particularly worried about in average
itself because the market self will
adjust the venture capitalists in
general are not stupid enough to pay a
premium consistently they might pay
premium for a short period of time but
they will adjust themselves and when you
look at so quarter on you know bubble if
most company are just creating a lot of
you know so-called users without
providing value to users that's
something which are worried but if you
look at uber and Airbnb right I mean
clearly these are the truth one of the
you know truth of this you know startup
or company which which become very
successful they do creating a lot of
values right I mean uber clearly has
provide you know the most efficiency
most efficient transportation you know
you know systems for all the people
around the world and Airbnb has creating
new demands and something which hotel
industry and having never been you know
you know thought about so I think these
are is a creating new demand or increase
if efficiency big time so I think
ultimately you know the value will be
you know are created by those companies
I'm not particularly worried that if
there's any so-called in a bubble
because the company my ahead of itself a
little bit for valuations if you look at
it you know China back in you know 1999
where there's a you know bunch of
company like see chip like you know
Baidu it's difficult to comment on a
valuation at each stage but what is
important is that they do bring value to
the companies out through the hole
economy what what I'll be very war about
is when those companies are quitting a
very similarly I want to raise a you
know a use one you know examples back in
2000 no one and 2002 there's a bunch of
company coda SP companies in China I
don't know if you guys still remember
maybe you know some of those you are now
living in China at the time they
providing either linked homes or
pictures for the China Mobile China
Unicom etc and most of company and died
or had been sold and so itself is not an
issue the issue is when they you know
the company sold the company almost
disappear it's not like a YouTube or
Instagram they're there and the
providing value to you this why does
company disappear and at one point they
are very very profitable because they
charge a part of the you know you know
they um they change cha they charge you
the fees through China Mobile and China
Unicom
it could be very profitable because the
value creating is just so seen people do
not need that middleman China Mobile
can't do it themselves after they fill
out so that's why I was worried : that's
the real bubble if you talk about you
know the bubble in the last 10 to 15
years in China
those SP company as a whole is a bubble
and if we can avoid that I think they
know the Omo startup environment is
really housing great well before we end
Neil one last question
so as a really successful entrepreneur
itself and now being the entrepreneur
behind entrepreneurs what advice would
you have where aspiring entrepreneurs
here in the audience as they look to
build something new I think you know you
have to go with your heart you know it's
it's difficult to make a perfect choice
um and at least in my cases are that
each time when I make a choice I say one
whether this go with the big trend
secondly probably more important which
do something you really like it
right when I you know was working at a
torch bank and in the last you know sort
of you know you know a year or so in 99
in in in in in ninety nine nine I really
really was excited by you know the
intent development in China I really
want to do something if I weren't gonna
do it if I'm not gonna do see chip I
would do something else but seach
himself fits me well because I love
Charlie at the same time I think jeans
and I can change you know people's life
in China so you have to really love um
what do you do otherwise it's gonna be
difficult to sustain you know a if you
think this is just a big trend but
that's something which you don't like or
you don't know whether you like or not
then if you work there for like you know
six months and twelve months you'll
probably feel like oh I want to jump to
next trend I do notice there's some
entrepreneur like that you know I was
you know you know we had this Monday
meeting and then you know when some and
shouldn't come to visit and ask him so
why I want to do say you know do this
intrapreneurship
all b2b is is hot or big data at all but
the question fundamentally is do you
think you have the best fit for this and
do you really have passion for that and
that's you know a question you should
ask yourself and no matter what other
people's interest you should find your
interest and follow your heart and find
the stuff you are passionate about it
and do it alright thank you so much Neal
will pleasure having you here today